too many deaths oh not enough of them
and what happened to Peter's helmet
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 may have
just touched down in theaters and fans
have thoughts spoilers ahead for
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3. James
Gunn wanting to work with his wife
Jennifer Holland is apparently the
internet's equivalent of wearing socks
with sandals to The More The Usual
Suspects of film Twitter have painted
The Narrative that Gunn always finds a
way to cast Holland in his Productions
and they see it as a form of Hollywood
nepotism considering Holland appears as
administrator qualin Guardians of the
Galaxy volume 3. her Cameo has started
the conversation again truth be told
quell's role in the story is minor and
it isn't like gun throughout an
established performer to make room for
his wife on screen some fans have come
to Holland and guns to fans pointing out
how the filmmaker is often cast the same
actors in his movies before and there
has never been any complaints about it
one tweeted it's no secret there's a
subset of geek fandom that are
unashamedly misogynistic but the hate
for Jennifer Holland being a James Gunn
Mainstay is so clearly sexist when you
just start naming Michael Rooker Sean
Gunn Nathan Fillion and so on and the
build up to Guardians of the Galaxy
volume 3 fans are excited by the
prospect of seeing Adam Warlock make his
live-action debut the character had been
teased before in the MCU first he would
now be portrayed in Flesh and Blood by
Will Poulter but this version of the
being first introduced as him and the
pages of 1967's Fantastic Four Comics is
much different than fans might have
imagined one ready to said polter was a
weird choice to play the character and
added that the makeup was quote TNG side
character tier it became pretty clear
they weren't going for perfect when they
cast me
in a different direction with the role
for some viewers the role isn't as
substantial as it should have been with
polter's warlock featuring scarcely in
the film another redditor said nothing
against his performance but I feel like
he could cut him out of the movie and
nothing will be lost his connection to
the plot was very flimsy others are not
impressed by how his personality has
been diluted here with James Gunn making
him a comedic and somewhat childish Fish
Out of Water character one minute to
described him as yet another himbo idea
and Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2 the
audience was introduced to the golden
High Priestess of The Sovereign a race
of beings created by the high
evolutionary Aisha is a minor antagonist
but she plays a vital role in the
creation of Adam Warlock which is teased
in the post-credits scene of the film I
think I shall call him
Adam in Guardians 3 Aisha returns with
her son Adam and toe as they do the high
evolutionaries evil bidding
unfortunately she has blown to
Smithereens on counter Earth and
presumably doesn't survive the events of
the movie while Aisha does have a few
sporadic scenes scattered throughout
there are a few fans puzzled by her
overall purpose in this storyline as
what medicine suggested there was an
opportunity to see both her and warlock
face off against a high evolutionary and
bring closure to that part of the story
instead she becomes glorified cannon
fodder
since the first time fans met rocket
it's clear he went through some trauma
in his past he doesn't like to talk
about it and his history has been
largely shrouded in secrecy until now
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 shows him
as a tiny and cute as a button baby
raccoon that becomes a part of high
evolutionary sick experiments it's made
even worse when the viewers meet
Rocket's three new adorable friends Lila
the USA thieves the walrus and Flor the
Rubber and see what has been done to
them as well sure they are upbeat about
life in general but there's no disputing
they have been tortured while James Gunn
doesn't get graphic in the depiction of
animal abuse it's the things left and
said that leave an unsettling feeling in
the pit of the stomach this hasn't been
lost on the fans either as the animal
lovers have expressed how difficult it
is to watch these scenes and not be
impacted by it of course this is the
intention of the filmmakers animal
lovers on Reddit said they were brought
to tears with one sharing when Lila was
shot I looked over and saw my wife
crying the MCU loves to sprinkle its
films and TV shows with numerous moments
and jokes as a way to provide levity to
the stories the Guardians have always
been the biggest jokers of the pack and
their appearances have contained the
most amount of humor out of all of the
MCU projects while the trailers for
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 showed off
a darker serious tone than most fans
might have expected no one should have
been surprised that the film would find
a way to incorporate some laughs most of
the comic relief comes from the
interactions between dragster destroyer
and mantis but there's also a recurring
gag between Cosmo the space dog and
kraglan some however have criticized the
film for having lame jokes one moviegoer
tweeted a good chunk of the jokes were
pretty unfunny and it seemed like Gunn
didn't know what to do with a lot of the
cast another said they quote a cringe
drawing a lot of the humor this time
around make no mistake about it comic
book fans are among the most perceptive
people in the world they missed nothing
and will let filmmakers know if
something is a mess one of the hottest
debates surrounding Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 is about the lack of
star-lord's helmet unlike the past
movies Peter the quilt doesn't utilize
it here and many fans have wondered why
it is missing from the action it is
considered an important part of the
hero's attire so it isn't the same
league as Captain America and his mighty
Shield I read a thread about the topic
has been started with one commenter
suggesting that Star-Lord wouldn't have
almost died in space that he activated
his helmet another user countered the
argument by saying that quill and the
others left in a hurry to try and save
rocket so he may have forgotten his
helmet back at the base the Guardians of
the Galaxy volume 3 trailer promised
sadness fans feared the worse for a
member of the crew with most presuming
rocket would be the one to perish and
because this marks the end of the
trilogy it was always likely that
someone would get killed as part of a
narrative beat in the end all the
Guardians are safe and no one heads off
to Valhalla to meet up with Jane Foster
I see you're dead now ah yeah but that
doesn't mean the other characters are
quite as Lucky in one of the most
hard-shattering scenes of the film Lila
thieves and the floor don't get to see
the blue sky with rocket as he prepares
to escape in a flashback sequence they
might have been fresh characters
introduced in this film but these three
wholesome creatures leave a significant
Mark with their kindness many viewers
have expressed how horrified they were
to see the events unfold according to
one redditor I just knew Lyla teased
some floor were going to die but their
deaths really got me forget about Peter
Parker telling Tony Stark that he
doesn't feel so good this is now
officially the saddest moment in a
Marvel movie
there are several moments in Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 where James Gunn
pulls a rug out from under the viewers
and makes everyone believe that someone
is a Gunner a particularly harrowing
scene occurs toward the end of the film
when Star-Lord doesn't escape in time
and floats through space his body begins
to freeze and his face blows to look
like a puffer fish Adam Warlock becomes
a hero as he flies out to Peter Quill
and saves him the puffiness disappears
from Quill's face not too long afterward
and it seems like it was only intended
for a gag even so there are fans who
don't understand the point of this one
Reddit says suggested that it made quill
look more like Pedro Pascal while
another reminded everyone that this
wouldn't have happened that he worn his
helmet we'll all fly away together
one last time the ending of Guardians of
the Galaxy volume 3 signifies the end of
a chapter and the start of a new one the
core team is dismantled as the majority
of the Guardians go off in separate
directions to find what they need in
their lives in their place a new set of
Guardians led by Rockets steps out in
the mid-credits scene presumably as the
new iteration of the group for the MCU
while it was always clear that this
would be James Gunn and many cast
members Las hurray this turn of events
to upset a lot of fans one Twitter user
said but sad that the group splits up
but I'm hopeful to see what the future
holds farewells are never easy but this
wasn't necessarily A Goodbye moreover
see you later considering that all of
these characters are still alive in the
MCU there's always a chance that their
past could cross again each member of
the Guardians of the Galaxy suffers in
the third film but they all get their
happily ever after in the end we see
some strong character progressions and
developments as the core characters
realize there are aspects of their lives
I need to work on independently but
they're all able to off into the sunset
and smile at their friends while doing
so
hahaha
hey some fans feel let down by this
decision to give everyone a peaceful
ending they expected Bloodshed and
waterfalls of Tears as a group got
ripped apart and destroyed on screen the
fans also aren't too pleased by the fake
outs we're led to believe that Drax
Star-Lord and Rockets have been wiped
out for good one way to explain I'm fine
with no member dying even though they
hinted so strongly at it but doing three
fake out deaths is just Overkill in my
opinion especially having one straight
up Flat Line some even negatively
compared this to Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker which annoyed fans by doing a
similar thing be that as it may this is
the MCU not Game of Thrones unlike
George R.R Martin Kevin feige isn't
casually killing off main characters in
the post-credits scene of Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 Tech splashes on the
screen stating the legendary Star-Lord
will return or the mid-credits team
showcases a new version of the team what
this indicates is that the guardian
story isn't quite over yet sure the
original incarnation of the squad might
not be keeping up anytime soon but there
are more Cosmic Tales left in the MCU
tank while this will be good news to
many fans there are others who are
annoyed by this ones with a user bemoans
the decision explaining how the lack of
a decisive conclusion is more harmful
than good here they said as much as I
liked it I think Guardians of the Galaxy
volume 3 highlights a major problem with
the MCU at the moment there's no real
finality to anything and at that point
what's the point it's a fair comment
with no end point in sights or decisions
are simply about moving the franchise
forward not necessarily toward anything
impactful on the other hand a cinematic
shared universe is about the journey not
the destination
so it's a different kind of Storytelling
model
[Music]
foreign